thank you
[Music]
in Mexico there's a Detention Center
where they hold people that are
traveling from like Central America
upwards you mean like it's like the the
like you're not from around here are you
you gotta get rounded up
I think it's in Center
no it's kind of like where uh where you
end up being held when you're let's say
you you want to claim Asylum or you want
to like uh migrate North you pass
through we get processed they gotta vet
who you are oh like a refugee situation
like that yeah yeah I see okay so um
it's kind of like it's I'm guessing it's
sort of like in Scarface in the
beginning
so they end up in these processing
centers uh for for a pretty long time
sometimes and then sometimes they just
end up getting deported back other times
they get granted entry
um and for some reason one of the
migrants in there started a fire inside
the detention center by like lighting up
the mattresses God damn it was he trying
to do a barbecue or something that's
usually how you do a barbecue light up a
mattress inside a Detention Center
so the um so the fire started and
usually like
um the staff of the Detention Center
supposed to open the doors when that
happens because there's no other way out
they didn't do that and 39 people died
oh 39. yeah all of them migrants yeah
what did they do were they like oh well
we can't afford letting them loose into
our society so they're just left they're
just what do we do I it's kind of weird
because at first I was like yeah are
they supposed to just like
is it really just let them out or not
but apparently they're now being charged
some of those murder that are the stuff
that we're supposed to act at that
moment are being charged as well that's
like a second degree murder as well as
the person that started the fire yeah
with the guy that started the fire he's
alive
yeah what a [__] scumbag it starts a
fire and runs
wait wait was the guy who started fire
one of the people that was supposed to
be held in detention yeah so do you
think how did he get out there yeah how
do you survive I don't know
that's crazy were there people that were
like working at the Detention Center
that got harmed too or is it just 39
people that died were migrants
there are people that did get hurt I
think there's like 17 or 18 people that
have injuries but in the moment like
jiggling their keys like who's got the
key and then they're trying to get the
right team that's kind of not that but
it does explain that uh they were like
stupid it does explain that there were
like a couple guards in front of the
door just kind of running back and forth
not knowing panicking kind of a deal
that's one of my biggest fears is like
freezing like I know there's so many
stupid people that like have
responsibility right yeah so like
when it comes to like the system like
like the government or or people who's
in charge of law enforcement you better
[__] hope the person that's
processing you or whatever has common
sense or has a quick wit or whatever
because if you got a dumbass this
thing's like these kind of thing happen
or if you got keys like this oh holy
[__] you'll be a genius and that's like
solving a [__] Rubik's Cube this is
Ryan's Keys we have been wondering for a
long time what the [__] is all this for
I'll I'll explain them and he reduced it
he used to have more I have way more
used to look like a high school
janitor's key set yeah it looks like
that looks like a public school district
Key set that's it's crazy that the guy
who started the fire still made it out
like I I could understand if it's like
maybe that guy knew the rules like well
I can't get out of the Detention Center
so if I start a fire they by law or by
code they have to open the doors or
something like that but the idea that
like they couldn't open the doors and 39
other people died but he still somehow
got out yeah how come no one follows
suit or like yeah don't even lock the
door behind him no that's the thing like
I don't know how the building floor plan
was but I it doesn't say that everybody
in the building died
so like maybe just those 39 people just
happen to be the ones that stuff died of
smoking smoke inhalation when I think of
detention centers though it to me it
just sounds like it looks like jail like
there's cages there's just like lobsters
on the floor everywhere yeah I've seen
those things it was highly politicized a
couple years back yeah all those yeah
even in the beginning of Scarface he
started a fire to try to do that because
they have to do like quick little
background checks right to see if like
all you guys cartel are you kidnapped
are you whatever like are you are you
who you say you are are you a fugitive
and then they have to go through all the
the checks and stuff and then you know
bring them through so full that kids are
taking turns like sleeping on the ground
because there's no room damn [__]
jeez yeah isn't there like some crazy
[__] going on right now where um there's
a lot of migrants coming through Mexico
El Paso right where they storm the uh
and they're not Mexican they're like
Central American or whatever Honduran
yeah yeah and then just ran through it
was like a couple thousand of them yeah
but then again it wasn't all at one time
yeah they just bomb rushed crazy videos
of just them storming through the
capital uh the capital sorry guys I've
just been watching some videos back to
your old experience exactly they storm
through the gates and they just ran
through yeah yeah I saw that you know
what's interesting to me is like so from
80s 90s and on right I remember
all of these presidential speeches were
like uh you know there's a place for
refugees like like after the Vietnam War
they had so many like camps set up
bringing people in
um you know Central America all that
stuff they would constantly bring people
and bring and then they had this
different
kind of model
now on both ends of the spectrum right
or left
they're saying don't come and I'm just
like that's so weird like when uh the
vice president
um when she made a speech about don't
come I was like it was crazy when
Democrats are saying don't come what the
[__] is happening that means they're in
charge again so now they have to say
don't come and then when Republicans are
in charge they have to say don't come so
it's whoever's not in charge they get to
scrutinize and say what you could you
have the best plan and once we're in
we'll do it differently and they just do
the same [__] every time because
Republicans they always had the model of
like oh we're good Christians we have to
let them in and then Democrats were more
like oh we gotta let them in because
like whatever humanitarian right so they
both had their own reasons to let them
in but they also have their own reasons
to not let them up and it's so [__]
what like what's the right one yeah I
mean in the grander scheme isn't letting
more people coming in
um higher potential for a growing
economy it's close to me theoretically
yeah theoretically but then there's also
so in the past I believe most people
were that were coming in
um assimilated much easier because
before there weren't um
it wasn't like the culture and education
was so freaking different that when they
came to the states it was so much harder
to integrate them but now it's like
different people from different
countries are it's not the same
countries like it's not like people from
Japan Vietnam
um you know European Eastern European or
whatever it's whole a whole new
different group and I think we're facing
a whole different set of like
these cultural clashes challenges yeah
yeah but it's also politicized that's
the part that sucks because it's like
right you watched Bill Clinton in the
90s and he's like we gotta Tamp down on
immigration you watch George W he says
the same [__] yeah you watch Obama he
says the same [__] Trump said the same
[__] so the same she didn't let any of
the refugees that were running from the
Middle East come Obama deported more
people than Trump did like but it's all
the same like unit party [__] we all are
aware of it but then everyone in
politics in like political season then
they make it all these big issues but
then they don't do anything about it but
there'll be random moments when they do
open up the gates though that's the
weird thing is like why is it that some
situations they'll be like
give me your tired poor sick and hungry
or whatever yeah if there's cameras
there or if there's votes to be won yeah
it could be AOC or outside those cages
remember that
oh yeah wearing all white doing the the
farce photo shoot that she had too if
you're gonna like cry like why you gotta
put your arm up like this [__] it was
wild she did a photo shoot take but I
actually think like there's probably a
flow that they have to figure like we
need about 10 million more people all
right let's let them in and then cut it
and then we're like let's see what
happens and they're like oh we need more
like five five million more and then
they bring them in there's also the
whole thing about like preferred people
that they want in here yeah you know
what I mean like Indian Engineers
well the ultimate said CEOs yeah the
ultimate cynical and maybe even
realistic
is like we know big businesses like
Tyson's Chicken all this stuff want like
very cheap labor yeah we just did a
story about that remember and they can
use you know their immigration status
against them if they try to get raises
and [__] like that yeah it's just
totally exploitative well I think they
want migrant workers temporarily they
don't want citizens because the
difference is citizens are entitled to
certain better rights you can get uh
vacation workers from different
countries to work our factories or
whatever whatever just keep rotating
them out well yeah it's like what's a
union yeah exactly yeah so it might be
like those reasons there's so many
different reasons like the only reason
why the U.S is still a profitable
Western Nation because we don't have a
population decline like the way that a
lot of European countries are yeah so
but the crazy thing too is like you know
the Green Card Lottery do you guys know
about that so like certain countries
they you could sign up for this Lottery
system where you basically submit your
name and there's a chance that you'll
just randomly get a green card to the
United States yeah wow for some freaking
reason that happened to my buddies yeah
I've never heard of it for uh like
anyone Asian but like smack got that and
so did like three of her friends really
whoa are they all Australian yeah so
it's kind of like it's a lottery
is it really a lottery or are they just
kind of like hey we want these ones and
maybe not so much these ones of course
it's not a lottery when the [__] did we
ever think [__] was actually the way it
was it was so cynical that's so true
it is a it is a hard subject though man
because like
it's like we're all I mean it's a nation
of immigrants right and then like
gatekeeping that and uh and also saying
like which ones will shine and which
ones won't right you know like how would
you [__] know yeah because in every
wave of immigration
from poor groups right there's gonna be
like criminal Enterprises that come
along oh I'm not sure that happened with
Irish that happened with like Jewish
that happened with Italian yeah and then
now like they're integrated and
Americanized to the point where like
they're not looked upon as the poor
population with criminal Enterprises
right there's like now they're like so
American now they're judging other
immigrants that are coming in when they
used to be not considered white right so
then every era I think we're gonna have
these like oh no we're more American
than you whereas like dude
that's so stupid because your ancestors
were also like being treated like you
weren't as American yeah that's the
cycle it's the cycle yeah it's like with
gangs in New York yeah like they call
themselves the natives but they were
just a few Generations away from the
other guys right yeah and I think that's
why a good movie though
it's a great movie
[Music]